one of the best in the business with the
ear to the ground of my compadre from
the nfl media group at rap sheet
joined the many many hundreds of
thousands and millions to
follow his knowledge he's here on the
rich eisen show how are you ian
rappaport i'm good rich
um i have never heard that clip before
obviously i'm a regular
advertising show listener i'm just
saying that particular clip i haven't
heard yes you know what was interesting
to me
okay what was that he he never said no
like
you went through the whole thing and
you're like oh what if tom says
and he and he just says oh i'm chilling
he literally never
said no and i of course you know heard a
million gronk interviews during his
one-year hiatus
he never ever quite said i'm definitely
not coming back if tom asks
and i just never you know until i got
the word that he was going to be
uh traded from the patriots to the bucks
i never really thought about it like
that but i think we all should have
that was pretty telling well i mean it
was the
july of 2019 we just played a clip for
our peacock audience
uh waiting for the radio audience to
return and um
you know i just had fun saying let's
play act out a phone call since you're
you know into acting right now because
that's
you know that was when he was dancing
with the laker girls and he was
just doing everything just popping up
everywhere
spiking a lego version of steve harvey
on a new year's eve
fox show you know just being gronk um
and just say hey dude is it possible if
you want to come back role-playing and
and it did happen and it's unbelievable
man i mean i talked about it yesterday
ian um two touchdowns for him in the
super bowl
and brady doing it like the the fact is
the question well how's brady and gronk
gonna do in this first year in tampa we
asked
that was that was the number one
question asked of me whenever i was on a
zoom with anybody
or anybody was uh tweeting with me or
whatever and the fact that the answer is
this is
is totally off the charts how how do you
think this is
playing out in patriot land right now
today well first of all you know it's
interesting to me too
um and i've read some some stuff today
sam farmer had a really good article on
on bruce arians and it reminded me that
when brady was
you know shopping for a team hold on
dude
i love it i'm on the rich heisman show
buddy
there you go i mean
you know if i was on some like low rent
show then i would say maybe hope but i'm
on the rich eyes
please tell your child to understand the
gravity of the situation
wait a parent thank you this is what i'm
saying
um so whenever brady would talk to teams
whether the chargers or the bucks or
whoever he would always say that he
wanted gronk to join him and i don't
know that they actually believed him and
the fact that it happened
and then gronk scores two touchdowns in
the super bowl
of course it's the most obvious thing
ever but it's also surreal
i mean it's gronk is amazing and
obviously brady
um is you know is what he is i would say
as far as the patriots go
i don't get the sense that they're like
upset
because they're in such different places
brady is going for it every year with
brady you are going for it
and i think new england this was
definitely a rebuilding year cam newton
obviously didn't work out
but they're trying to get the salary cap
in place they're trying to build again
for the long term and i just don't think
their visions matched up in a way that i
probably didn't realize
11 months ago so then this is a great
way to turn to the quarterback carousel
that is spinning um what what is new
england's plan to
acquire their next
quarterback is it jared stidham is it
the guy that they
decided to place to the side
to see how cam would do in the first
non-brady year
what what is their plan they were
kicking the tires on stafford didn't
obviously work out what
what is their plan right now
yeah um and you know they were they were
definitely in on stafford uh but i think
they knew that
you know i saw the headline from tom
curran who i love
um and i don't think he's wrong i got
the sense that it was more
stafford wanted mcvay and wanted la more
than he didn't want anywhere else like
the panthers had a really really good
offer too
and they they were never getting
it because i think the lions tried to do
right by staff but
um as far as new england goes i mean
they're going to be in on all the
quarterbacks i i don't
not carson wentz but um some of the
other quarterbacks you know if
if there are cars available if marcus
mariota is available
um if the sean watson is available to
garoppolo is available
um i think they're going to be you know
if jameis winston
uh potentially doesn't go to the saints
i would imagine they'd have some
interest there they're just
you know i would think they're gonna be
in on every single one
and you know try to do this all over
again
i'm just not sure which one they're
gonna end up with but they're going to
try and then of course there's the draft
but uh
for the moment though that's we can hit
that from
uh new league year all the way to draft
night
uh in april for the time being though
let's let's dig into
uh everything on the quarterback front
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show what is the scoop with carson wentz
as you and i converse right now yeah
well uh he is still currently a member
of the philadelphia eagles
um and you know i don't mean to sound
like sean mcvay when he said uh no
less need when he said jared goff is our
quarterback right now whatever
for the moment right um i mean less is
the greatest but that was the biggest
tell of all time
um you know so he's he's still a member
of the eagles could he return
anything is possible i would not say
it's likely at all
but possible i don't get the sense
anything is imminent
you know the cults of that interest the
bears of that interest
maybe a couple other teams have had
calls but to me it's
mostly those two um and i know there was
a lot of momentum
you know like on friday and then maybe
kind of saturday i was like all right
maybe this could happen soon but then
you get through saturday it doesn't
happen you get through the super bowl
doesn't happen
didn't happen yesterday and it this is
just kind of my read on the situation
it's almost like everyone took a deep
breath
and we're like all right hang on like
why are we hurrying
um and it felt like everyone kind of
went back to their own corners
and like let's figure out what we would
give up what we want to do and
kind of what we want for the future
right so what does a trade look like
because we saw
what a trade looked like for stafford
because it involved goff and his
equally hefty contract and
and and golf went obviously to
detroit in a trade so
no quarterback's going to be coming back
to philadelphia
right i mean because it's going to be
hertz or if they want to draft another
one they can
so what what is the construct that
you're hearing about for a deal
potentially for once what does it look
like
i mean if if the the bears need to shed
salary they could also trade polls
you know i don't know if that would be
the craziest thing in the world um
so i wouldn't be totally surprised to
see that
um but you know the the stafford goth
deal is really a problem because usually
you know one trade set the precedent for
another trade right so laramie tonsil
goes for
two first rounders and then jaylen
ramsey goes for two first rounders and
then
bottoms goes for two first rounders
usually you know those were sort of
apples to apples you can compare um
that makes sense the jared goff contract
really makes it extremely difficult to
compare because of course how
roseman would want two ones you know
well
if the lions got two ones why shouldn't
i have two ones but
the two future ones and they had to take
on jared goff's contract
was not a good point of comparison i
mean i think they'll be able to get a
first rounder
that would be very good considering the
way carson played
i just don't know what levels of more
they're going to be able to get
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show okay
let's get to deshaun watson in houston
he clearly wants out
and the texans are what like their plan
is to dig in and eventually he'll return
david cully's call
or eventually they'll get him in a room
and they'll take their shot there
and then figure out what the next step
is
hopefully they don't need a next step
because watson will say i love this guy
and i don't care about however i felt
about management or
uh you know jack easterby whose
catskills routine made it uh on twitter
and youtube quite a bit over the last
week
so uh like is that their plan is that
their plan for deshaun watson right now
they they are trying very hard to get
desean back
um to bring him back to reel him back in
just just trying to get him to talk it
hasn't happened yet but they are trying
uh david colley is trying i know that
the real problem here rich
is that david colley did nothing to
deshaun watson
nick casirio also did nothing to deshaun
watson
the way nicosia was hired is a problem
but he didn't do anything wrong and i
don't get the sense
desean watson has any animosity at all
to nicosia
so everything they are trying to do
in a weird way doesn't matter because
they didn't do anything to them so it's
not like they need to apologize or
something like that because
they did nothing wrong it's about the
owner
and management and
how do you fix that i mean and i don't i
don't get the sense to sean is
changing either he's still extremely
upset i don't know how it
ends um i just don't see any end in
sight
well i mean the end is is for the
houston texans
is they either you know there's three
options they hope the first one is that
that watson talks to colley and says boy
i love this guy
i believe in him i'm gonna buy what he's
selling and it doesn't matter
anything else that that's unchanged that
that caused me to demand the trade
that that's that's the best case
scenario and the other two scenarios are
that they force him
to to hold out take his money
or three they trade like that's that's
it you know or
or they force him to hold out and then
don't take his money sort of what
jerry did to zeke you know um and then
pay him and then give him what he wants
the problem is what he wants is
something i guess would be the sale of
the team
i i like to me it's just it it makes no
sense when you saw
what they were able to or what what what
the
lions were able to acquire and i
understand that that
that was financial because of the the
size of the contract they took on
but that could be an apple to apple
basically saying hey
the lions technically did get two firsts
for a 30
now three-year-old quarterback desean
watson
they could basically they could get the
jets entire draft
uh first round uh haul for the next
three years
and maybe demand darnold on top of it
and get a kid
who is 23 with two years contractual
control i mean after a while
the the the the writing is on the wall
and a better future you know
than making your superstar beloved
athlete hold out on you that there's
gonna be a better option right
that's that's to me and that to me seems
inevitable
i don't know you tell me you did a great
job
of explaining why this is an impossible
situation
we really did because you know all
someone involved has a major problem
with every scenario
you just like there's not one where it's
like okay fine this actually makes sense
for both sides
in all those scenarios someone has a
huge huge problem and
wants to do everything to stop it from
happening um and so
you know as far as the trade hall i mean
it's going to be as big as we've ever
seen
and i honestly don't know you know the
jets could do it if you would want to go
there
right um i'm not sure who else i mean
the dolphins
could and then that would probably make
some sense but then they have two
issues if they even would do it which i
don't know that they would
um but there's not a lot of teams that
can just do it because
you know a first-rounder this year round
or next year
okay first round of the year after but
that's like so far into the future we
don't know anything about that
so is it like all right two full draft
boards for two years
is it two first rounders and like many
many really good young
cheap players like i just it's hard for
me to
count that high as far as a possible
trade
especially when i know that nicosia
doesn't want to do it it's impossible
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show let's get into russell wilson
you saw what uh your colleague and your
predecessor
nfl network jason lachanford tweeted out
about the number of sacks that russell
wilson's taken and his team has grown
increasingly frustrated
your first report on super sunday ian on
nfl game day morning was the fact that
people are calling
the seahawks asking for russell wilson
to see if he's available and
being told to pound sand they're not
interested but we all know
why would anybody call for a 32 year old
quarterback coming off of the best year
that he's had
um statistically in quite some time
despite what might be going on unless
there's something going on
and there's always been rumors about it
not being
all copacetic there what is going on
with russell and the seahawks um
i would say here is my read on the
situation so
you know last year the offense didn't
work very well at all right i think
that's
pretty obvious um especially at the end
of the year then they hi
you know they ended up hiring an office
accordion and russell wilson was
involved in that um but
i think you know there were some moments
where i think he was frustrated with
some of the candidates being considered
and
in the end they ended up consulting with
him and he had a huge role in the actual
hire um but when teams see a run first
offense
a run first coach the offense is not
working
they start to wonder if the quarterback
is upset and they start calling
and they start talking because i think
some of them were in person but they
start talking
and i didn't get the sense that seahawks
would all um
you know want anything to be done but
there's some stuff there
um and you know desean watson is not the
only franchise quarterback would like to
have some conversations um so you know
does he get traded
i don't know but probably not um
however because of the atmosphere in the
nfl right now
basically every everyone calls in every
quarterback so
i don't know i mean i've seen crazier
things so
um throat let's throw everybody into the
mix here um
carr and matt ryan and um
i'm definitely i'm sure leaving some
name jimmy g who
who crystal ball it for me in my final
ask for you here on this situation
um who does move who do you think by the
end of the day
does get moved that was i guess a week
one starter for their team
last year or a bulk of the season
starter for their team
last year at quarterback um i hope you
don't mean by the end of today
because my lovely wife uh is out at she
has a hair appointment and i have to
watch the boys so if there is a trade
would be very problematic for me hey
look we already heard jude's on the
loose man so
uh whatever defense you're running uh
it's
you're in the cover one right now or
you're cover two right you got your your
man short
what's that's going on there so um
my best to you um jude asked for
something
it could have been a snack it could have
been to play abc uh on the computer i
had no earthly idea what he asked for
again like i said excellent parenting
skills
outstanding um so i guess by the end of
the figurative
day not the end of today but by the end
of the figurative day
which quarterback do you think gets
moved or quarterbacks
so i think carson probably gets moved
somewhere okay
um i don't get the sense derek card
teams are calling
i don't get the sense derek carr does
but mariota could get traded
um that's actually kind of a really
interesting option because he played so
well when he played
he did um you know it'd be hilarious if
he's this
year's ryan tannehill after ryan
tannehill became ryan tannehill by
bouncing him that would be something
ironic there
um you know i think those those are
probably the two best bets and you know
darnold mike i think it's
very possible but i don't know a hundred
percent
to say he's definitely going to be
traded i just know there's a lot of
interest
and there's a obviously that could pick
a quarterback at number two they just
have to make sure that
there's someone they value there before
trading ian thanks for the time go uh go
be a parent now
uh best to you and and uh the rest of
your day
bless you sir thanks to call thanks
thank you
seeing rap about hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here